las primeras informaciones sobre esta
larga llamada telefónica de dos horas
entre putin y vaquero en llegaron desde
moscú fue el kremlin que informó que el
presidente ruso pidió a su homólogo
francés que se occidente quiere detener
las atrocidades en ucrania deje de
enviar armas a ese país y también
aconseje de manera apropiada a las
autoridades quien -según a moscú ellos
siguen abiertos al diálogo sin embargo
el presidente silencio y sus gobiernos
no están preparados para llevar
seriamente las conversaciones de paz
putin criticó también a la unión europea
porque no condena los crímenes de guerra
dijo él ni los bombardeos masivos que
realiza ucrania en el este del país
hablaron también de la evacuación de
civiles desde la planta de s'hostal en
mariupol gracias a la mediación de
naciones unidas- putin dijo que los
civiles son retenidos allí por
nacionalistas ucranianos el presidente
macrón en cambio pidió hablar de la
seguridad alimentaria puesta en riesgo
debido a este conflicto putin dijo que
es la responsabilidad de las sanciones
de occidente en contra de su país
recordemos que esta es la primera
conversación telefónica entre ambos
líderes desde el pasado 29 de marzo eso
es un poco antes de que se conociera la
masa de busca en la periferia de kiev
esas imágenes que dieron la vuelta al
mundo de civiles muertos en las calles
que el presidente macro calificó de
insoportables en ese momento macrón
pidió a las autoridades rusas hacerse
cargo de estos crímenes por cierto moscú
siempre ha negado ser el responsable de
esta masacre